it is an eerie image New York's famous
Skyline barely visible through a thick
blanket of smoke
this was mid-afternoon yesterday but it
looked more like dusk in Times Square
skyscrapers seemingly shrank as their
tops disappeared from View
and this hazy half-lite and acrid air is
currently hanging over much of
Northeastern America Millions have been
warned to avoid exercise and to stay
indoors the levels that people if they
were to be outside especially if they're
exercising breathing faster they're
going to be inhaling particulates at
concentrations at normal smokers would
inhale
the smoke is coming from Canada where
huge swathes of land are on fire in
Quebec alone north of New York more than
100 fires are considered out of control
the plumes of smoke blowing South are
even visible from space
the country's used to wildfires but
nothing like this a long period of warm
dry weather has brought with it
apocalyptic visions
an area roughly the size of Belgium has
already been burned experts say this is
climate change in action and that
conditions will only get worse one of
the big concerns is that we're about to
experience a unhelpful natural cycle at
the beginning of what is called El Nino
and that makes conditions around the
world even hotter it's like a
supercharging that will interact with
the existing climate change that humans
have caused uh and so we're probably
going to see even worse conditions as we
head into next year
it's meant thousands of people have been
forced from their homes and some
Villages abandoned to the elements
a threat to life there while further
afield a threat to health and with no
rain expected soon the smoke and the
dangers are likely to persist either
Bennett Sky News